et on va revenir justement sur ce
premier déplacement de jean castex qui a
été accueilli dans l'essonne par la mère
du coudray montceaux aurélie gros élu
dès le premier tour et nous sommes
justement en direct avec la première
maires de france à recevoir le premier
ministre
bonsoir aurélie gros merci beaucoup
d'être avec nous sur rt france alors
vous faites partie des élus avec cédric
villani notamment qui ont qui ont pu
parler au nouveau premier ministre
là quelles impressions vous alti la
donner bah écoute et une impression d'un
maire pragmatique un maire proche des
territoires et ça rassure pour une mère
comme moi qui nouvellement élus qui
souhaitent que le territoire soit remis
en avant qui a un nouveau un nouvel acte
de décentralisation est aujourd'hui les
propos du ministre ont été dans ce sens
donc plutôt un avis très positif donc
une écoute il vous a dit d'ailleurs
lui-même être un homme des territoires
il a dit aussi que la relance de
l'économie était sa priorité et ça
passera par justement un lien étroit
avec les élus locaux vous pensez que
c'est la bonne solution
un lien étroit blanc l'a vu oui
effectivement dans cette crise du
coronavirus qu'on a vécu une crise
sanitaire sans précédent les territoires
en jouer un rôle essentiel et le premier
ministre on a bien conscience a été le
ministre du déconfinement aujourd'hui
nous sommes dans la relance économique
et nous avons un ministre qui souhaite
que la relance économique
démare des territoires au plus proche
des territoires avec un partenaire
efficace les élus locaux
aujourd'hui pour penser différemment il
faut faire différemment et cette
nouvelle étape de décentralisation doit
être portée par tout le monde
les élus locaux mais aussi les hommes
d'état comme lui faut aussi avoir
confiance en l'état
est-ce que vous avez le sentiment que
jean castex aura les coudées franches
puisque c'est surtout la question qui se
pose avec emmanuel macron qui renforcent
en quelque sorte son hyperprésidence
vous y croyez voir assez coudées
franches pour jean castex qui est un
homme de terrain
oui oui je veux y croire en tout cas je
veux y croire je veux y croire pour les
nombreux élus locaux qui aujourd'hui
s'investissent au quotidien pour leur
territoire qui s'investissent
pour leur entreprise moi j'ai pu
échanger avec lui sur la laïcité c'est
rare d'entendre un premier ministre qui
dans son premier discours parle de
laïcité est aujourd'hui va reparler de
la laïcité mais on a aussi parlé de la
jeunesse vous savez que c'est un sujet
que je porte particulièrement avec moi
au mouvement national la france vraiment
la jeunesse qui font remobiliser autour
autour de nos territoires mais aussi
autour des grands enjeux qui fonde notre
pays ce pays
il faut remobiliser la jeunesse autour
de la citoyenneté et la démocratie
participative c'est des sujets en tout
cas qu'il porte à coeur il a bien
précisé que c'est nous les élus locaux
qui avons aussi cette chance d'être au
plus proche au contact des citoyens et
j'ai envie d'avoir confiance et j'ai
envie de me dire que notre belle france
va peut-être être dense dans des choses
plus positives et avec une relance
économique qui va être difficile on le
sait très bien avec une crise qui va
être intense en france à la rentrée
et aujourd'hui on doit tous être
mobilisés on ne peut pas être contre
l'état on doit tous travailler ensemble
et les élus locaux sont cette chance
cette chance en france et pour que le
gouvernement la saisissent et le
gouvernement qu'il entend depuis depuis
plusieurs mois d'ailleurs cet appel des
élus locaux sur sur le l'entreprise que
le nouveau premier ministre a visité
aujourd'hui elle est emblématique des
difficultés rencontrées on le sait en
france il ya beaucoup de plans de
licenciements en ce moment il dit
vouloir maintenir l'emploi favoriser
d'ailleurs même les relocalisations en
avez vous parlé avec lui on a parlé
effectivement relocalisation vous savez
il ya eu cette problématique notamment
autour du des masques qui a été un
grands sujets pendants ces différents
modes imaginer que les masses pente où
s'était acheté presque en chine
donc c'est le comble aujourd'hui pour
relocaliser et quand on regarde ce
fleuron de d'entreprise en essonne où
vous avez une entreprise qui est assez
exceptionnel sur les nanotechnologies
qui fabriquent nos puces de téléphone
parce que je le dis aussi pour les
téléspectateurs
c'est important de savoir qu'en france
il ya ses spécificités et aujourd'hui
ces entreprises là sont confrontés sont
confrontés à plusieurs pour la grille
n'ont pas arrêté pendant le confinement
ils ont continué et 7 jours sur 7
ils se sont équipés ils ont essayé de
trouver des solutions ils sont faits des
territoires mais ils sont encore
confrontées à la problématique du
recrutement alors qu'on sait que
beaucoup de français cherche encore de
l'emploi du recrutement qui souvent est
due aussi à la problématique des
transports et ces sujets là ont été ont
été échangés avec le premier ministre il
a été très à l'écouté et à promis en
tout cas aux entreprises d'être un
soutien et c'était un signe fort pour
eux clairement mais je rappelle que les
les régions avec valérie pécresse
notamment avec marc faure plan de
relance au niveau entreprise les
départements également se mobilisent et
on a rappelé qu' il fallait faire ça
conjointement on ne peut pas travailler
seuls aujourd'hui la la vie a changé en
france
les mentalités ont changé il faut que
les politiques changé et qu'on change
notre façon de faire de la politique
voilà pour les mots on va attendre les
actes un vent de juger son action il
valait la détailler d'ailleurs la
semaine prochaine avez vous parlé des
hôpitaux qui ont c'est en ile-de-france
ont grandement besoin aussi de d'un plan
de relance bien sûr on a échangé puisque
nous avons le centre hospitalier sud
francilien à corbeil-essonnes donc à la
frontière de ma ville le
coudray-montceaux nous avons échangé sur
les problématiques sur le personnel qui
s'est énormément investi et aujourd'hui
on ne peut pas faire fi des difficultés
que rencontre la la santé et j'en j'ai
eu l'occasion il ya quelques jours aussi
d'échanger avec le directeur de la rs et
de lui poser une question publiquement
sur la relance comment s'organiser le
système de santé la désertification
médicale
aujourd'hui il faut faire avec les
territoires ceux qui connaissent les
enjeux ses classeurs population c'est
les maires de proximité c'est les
départements et je crois que dans la
stratégie en tout cas de mathieu 4
stakes notamment sur la question du des
compliments ça là ça a été géré
notamment avec des départements donc il
ya une prise de conscience sur le fait
qu'il faut que ce soit relativement
locales et qu'on arrive à à mettre en
avant dans tout cas les initiatives de
proximité aujourd'hui les français les
citoyens ont besoin de proximité et de
pragmatisme proximité dans la production
également on l'a vu pendant cette crise
des français va l'acheter davantage de
produits qui ont moins d'empreinte
carbone l'écologie on a dit un mot on
l'attend aussi sur ce sujet là
évidemment je crois que des signes de
cette campagne municipale a été
notamment la montée de l'écologie
l'écologie aujourd'hui ne doit pas être
la compétence optionnelle entre
guillemets bogo je crois qu'aujourd'hui
tout le monde doit prendre conscience
que nous sommes dans une urgence une
urgence et ce virus nous l'a rappelé et
c'est pour ça que en échange notamment
sur ces enjeux écologiques
je crois qu'il ya une grande place à
donner à nos jeunes sur ces sujets là
qu'ils ont aussi des idées et je pense
qu'il faut arriver à maturité pour
donner de nouveaux droits à nos jeunes
notamment en matière de droits de vote
ce qui peut nous permettra de nous faire
évoluer peut-être sur nos politiques
publiques et notamment
celle de l'écologie qui doit être prise
de deux pleines mains à pleines dents
par tous les élus et non pas que par
l'état ça doit être totalement conjoint
alors on attend évidemment le nom des
prochains ministres avec vous quelques
indiscrétions et les gros ou pas non non
même si j'en avais merci beaucoup en
tout cas mais bon on ne doute pas que il
y aura peut-être des nouvelles
évolutions des changements et des choses
qui nous étonnerons autour de la
jeunesse et de la concertation citoyenne
par exemple on verra ça passe merci en
tout cas merci beaucoup d'avoir de nous
avoir donné la primeur de vos
impressions après avoir rencontré le
nouveau premier ministre
aujourd'hui merci aurait niveau